all right the draft today toughest
quarterbacks in the nfl we got to move
through this quickly because we are
truncated because of the royal ascot
coming up at 8 30 a.m eastern my first
pick and it took me a while to really
settle on this one because there were a
lot of tough quarterbacks and anybody
who plays quarterback in the nfl is
inherently tough this is degrees of
toughness give me deshaun watson of the
houston
the way he has been banged around in his
career and he doesn't have a big thick
ben roethlisberger frame he is fearless
he treats so many plays like it's the
last play of the super bowl he's not
afraid to get a hit he's not afraid to
get hurt he's trying to help his team
win
it maybe a little much because he is
putting himself at risk but i think he's
the toughest of all the quarterbacks he
is tough as hell and i don't know if he
would have been my first pick but i
think he would have been my second pick
for sure but you're right and he's not
like a real thick muscle guy but it's
unbelievable how he has no regard for
his body and of course we both love
watching them play so we both want to
say please have a little more regard for
your body because we don't want to see
you get hurt you're awesome and you're
fun to watch
i think you're missing on phillip rivers
though that's who i'm going with is the
toughest quarterback in football right
now to play as long as he's played the
style in which he's played which is just
you know you've seen him mike stand in
there and he passed the ball 74 times
and he does this and people are all
around him and he just still stands
there and pass the ball and then people
are dragging on him he pats it a few
more times and then throws it i mean to
me his consecutive start streak is uh
more impressive than the eli manning
just because of the physical nature in
which philip rivers plays and hangs in
the pocket and the fact that he hasn't
really been hurt ever in this long
career playing that way um i mean he's
got to be part caveman to pull that off
so it's uh he's tough as hell
you left out
the best argument i can't believe i'm
gonna give you this i can't believe i'm
gonna bolster your case he played he
played on the tournament
you left that out too late it's too late
it's too late i get going and i can't
think of all my damn facts i'm gonna
spit out sorry
i he was on my list and and you know
what maybe he should have been the first
pick i don't know but for deshaun watson
i also factor in that i think he's a lot
better than philip rivers right now so
that helps sway me i'm going to go with
ben roethlisberger next we now now look
he has a reputation
for embellishing from time to time
he has a reputation
for maybe
saying he's injured when he isn't i
remember after the afc championship game
in 2004 when the steelers lost to the
patriots ben's rook a year he said he
played the game with three broken toes
bill cower the coach of the team at the
time said he didn't have any broken toes
what the hell are you talking about but
still he stands in there he moves around
he takes hits he has been injured he's
only played all 16 regular season games
of a season four times in 16 seasons
which tells you he does take a lot more
punishment abuse than most quarterbacks
but he just keeps going the fact that he
hasn't retired yet it tough he doesn't
need the money
and at this point it would be very easy
for him to walk away and say i want to
be able to walk 10 years from now i want
to be able to run i want to be able to
do things but he keeps going and i think
that that that adds to the case even
though
even though
i i do have i do have a problem with the
embellishment from time to time yeah
still is one of the toughest
quarterbacks in the nfl yeah he well he
likes to let everybody know when he has
a little injury or he's bothered but
that still doesn't make up for the fact
like you're saying like he's tough as
hell when it comes to sunday playing
football and if he is if he is hurt and
has a chance to play he plays so i'm not
going to argue with you there at all i
mean he is to me uh big ben big soldier
he's as tough as they come and he'll
stand in there as long as he's got to
deliver the football i'm going to go
with dak prescott as my next pick i mean
first off dak prescott's built like a
greek god a lot of ways like a cam
newton you know you watched jack
prescott play quarterback the last few
years he's not afraid to lower his
shoulder or try to run over middle
linebackers you know dive into the end
zone get flipped do those things let
alone you know his butt and legs are
top-notch you know but he's got great
power he's tough in the pocket and he's
got a toughness when you meet him and
look at him mike you know that's why i'm
picking him too i've been around him
three different times in my life and
he's one of those guys that you look in
the eye and you go oh
if i pissed him off he would beat the
crap out of me and i think he would
enjoy it you did
discount he gave you that look oh if you
two weren't sitting on a mattress at the
time it could have gotten very ugly
yeah look hometown discount he's like
how about i hold it down
that's my man i hope he gets every penny
i hope he's not pissed at me for some of
the stuff we've talked about contract
still because i do root for him and i
want to see him get paid
four seasons in the nfl hasn't missed a
game and is very very tough this one is
difficult for me
um
i got two to choose from i got two
finalists i'm gonna go patrick my homes
here's why two things first of all
how quickly he came back from the knee
injury last year he was determined to
come back he doesn't care about his
physical well-being he wants to be out
on the field doing his thing a hopper on
one leg if he has to and then in the
super bowl remember the narrative that
got me in a little trouble because
everybody's thinking i'm telling the
49ers to go head hunting which clearly
wasn't the case we've established that
over and over again he knew what was
coming in the super bowl he knew they
were going to be physical with him and
he took it remember that play where he
got he got hit and he stood up and he
just kind of looked at the guy and he's
like yeah good hit bring it um and you
don't think of him that way but but uh
he is and and i think the toughest ones
are the ones where you just take it for
granted because right they don't have to
show you how tough they are they just
line up and play they take the pounding
and they just keep going without you
know oh my arm it's broken they just go
about their business
yeah he is he's not afraid you're right
another one where i want to go you know
be more afraid please because i don't
want you to get hurt but yeah i think
sometimes just because he's a he's a
handsome you know cute younger guy right
you don't think of it as tough but he
does play tough and he's not afraid to
throw his body around and i'm gonna go
with another handsome guy okay i mean
there's some there's some guys to pick
for here
but how can i not pick a quarterback
who's played 20 years in the nfl as a
pocket passing quarterback and yes i'm
not like
in love with his ability to stand in the
pocket right now at the age of 42. i
wish he would be a little bit better but
man the 18 or 19 years before that i
mean brady tom brady he's been hurt once
he'll stand in there compete get in the
face of the baltimore ravens tyrell
suggs ray lewis he never backs down from
anybody so i do when you talk about
toughness i think brady's as tough as
they come as far as in the pocket i
think he's mentally tough and that's why
he is you know arguably the greatest of
all time but i don't want him to be
underestimated in that category because
he is
really quickly others i had that didn't
make the list russell wilson matthew
stafford lamar jackson and carson wentz
carson wentz was the guy that i almost
took instead of my homes chris any any
other big names that stood out for you
we gotta go uh yeah i like all your
names i did think of cam newton and josh
allen too because of the way they play
and they're not afraid to contact so
those were two other i had on my list
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports